Jesus lived from what was written about him
we must learn this secret
he never lived by what was happening around him
he has gone back
to the foundation of the world
which is in the bible
he was the slaughtered lamp of god
for the foundation of the world
before there were people
before there was 1 world
god said
you will be the lamp that is slaughtered for people
Jesus came to earth with that knowledge
and he believed
I am the country of origin
he believed what was written of him
there is great wisdom in this for you and for me
to also discover which plan
god has set up for you
for the foundation of the world and take it